اوجه قصور في الانتخابات التركيه حددتها
منظمه الامن والتعاون الاوروبي من خلال
بعثتها لمراقبه العمليه الانتخابيه مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه التي اتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل خاطب السلطات التركيه لضمان
توفير الفرص العادله للمنافسين خلال جوله
الاعاده فقبل انطلاق الاستحقاق الانتخابي
في تركيا تلقت منصه تويتر اوامر قضائيه من
انقره لحجب بعض الحسابات وايضا التغريدات
التي تنتهك القواعد الانتخابيه وتمثل ما
تعتبره تهديدا للامن القومي القضيه بدات
عندما اتهمت السلطات التركيه تويتر باتاحه
خدماتها خلال الانتخابات التي جرت الاحد
الماضي على الرغم من التحذيرات لاحقا
دافعت تويتر عن موقعها وموقفها بانها
استجابت بالفعل لجزء من طلبات انقره قبل
يوم من الانتخابات وذلك بحجم اربعه حسابات
واكثر من 400 تغريده حددتها كما التركيه
طبعا حاله الجدل حول اجراء تويتر دفع
خبراء الحقوق الالكترونيه الاتهام الشركه
بانها باتت تتماهى في عهد ايلون ماسك مع
القرارات الحكوميه اصبحت اكثر اتجاها
لتقييد حريه التعبير تويتر عاده ودافعت عن
موقفها ايضا بانه كان اجراء احترازي
واستجابه جزئيه لطلبات السلطات في انقره
حتى لا تتعرض خدماتها في تركيا للانقطاع
يذكر ان الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات
التركيه شهدت تقدما لاردوغان على منافسه
كمال كليتش دار اوغلو قبل ان يدخل
المرشحان الى جوله اعاده في الثامن
والعشرين من مايو الجاريه لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات